what's that believe nation my name is
Evan my one word is believe and I
believe in people more than they believe
in themselves
and my sincere hope is that if you see
in yourself what I see in you you'll be
able to change the planet and so help
you on your journey I started the best
atony series as an experiment such a
test Tony Robbins has had an impact on
me and a lot of the viewers on my
channel and I thought maybe once a month
bring some of his best content that I
really enjoyed to inspire enlighten
motivate you and so today we're going to
learn from Tony on how we turn somebody
who had a lifelong stutter that really
held him back in life and he turned it
around and transformed the man's life as
well hope you enjoy my name is Rashad
bill I've on stuttered for as long as I
can remember my freshman year of college
one of the first courses that I took was
beat class and I throws the great I
received was an F I went from a
full-time Coast during my fellowship to
stocking shelves saw the big graveyard
shift and minimum wage the industry on n
is just basically instilled industry and
stuttering have gotten in the way of
closing a deal or even to schedule kind
of appointment I could have a more
successful career like I spoke fluently
[Music]
Tonie it would mean so much to me if you
could help us out with this better he's
such an incredible man and I know
there's so much more potential than he
had every day is a struggle for him his
stutter holds him back a lot and makes
him question himself it's so hard
because I can't do anything about it
20 if you can help that would just mean
so much to to me and to our family
Rashad nice to meet you well tell me a
little bit if you would about what's
going on your life I understand you're
having difficulty in terms of a speech
impediment or stuttering I just know in
my my life part rejected it I was
ashamed of it
I drew back in what's extremely
introverted but it accepted you've gone
through several stages that are perfect
stages gone through ashamed you've gone
through rejection and you've gone
through acceptance you've accepted this
experience now that you've accepted it
you can eliminate it yeah sign me up for
that right now okay now what you knows
we just said do that exactly is it yeah
sign me up for that right now say it
again yes I know for that right now
now you just spoke perfectly now there
are other parts of your speech that were
perfect as well but you just
demonstrated what I'm going to show you
it's hard as human being to figure out
what makes people do what they do but
because I spent 30 years in a hundred
countries with more than you know three
and a half million people at this point
I could be an idiot and I'd have to see
there's patterns that make people crazy
to make people happy to make them
fulfilled that make them stutter what
you know the pattern is so easy to
change
almost every unconscious pattern
happened a long time ago when we make a
decision about something we model
something a model of behavior or we
reject the behavior go deepen our
unconscious and becomes a pattern to
avoid pain or to gain pleasure when you
start stuttering tell me the moment what
your earliest memory what's your
earliest memory in life take a moment
your earliest memory in life probably
two years old get up on a Saturday
watching cartoons and eating cereal I
believe it was Rocky and Bullwinkle and
Bullwinkle does he have a spider who
Rocky
I'm not sure earliest memory and when
illegal got himself in trouble how did
he get out of trouble when somebody was
kind of like torture him or do something
bad to him he would scream out rocky
right and he always stuttered so I want
to do this all patterns like that happen
because you forgotten something that
happened right before that moment and
now you're locked in by the pattern
there's the decision you made or
something you experienced or life was
very different right before that moment
go back to right before that moment and
I want you to recapture what you forgot
my parents were probably arguing that
having quite often like to the point
where my PA got physical and you didn't
know what to do did you he did hilarity
and insurance just get it I got that
from hey rocky could the one thing lucky
always responded to was no I'm not just
a cry for help
stuttering cry for help
even a child can't consciously
understand if it feels helpless we'll
find a way to intervene and stop pain
going between those who loves and one of
the ways to do that is create a new
problem so you've found a way to protect
your mother stop your father from being
her and it worked
that was perfect for a two-year-old not
good for a xxx roba shot well so now
what can we stay - no no no no see - we
don't see you're a man thirty years old
live life that's all that stuff was a
warrior you're shot
feeling malaria's freedom in the
Warriors the ones who can face anything
and stormed to a warrior once he sent
his mind to it he will do whatever
battle is necessary for his wife for his
family for itself
make the sound of the warrior the first
sound that comes to make the sense out
of the way
the Word of God special ever on the
water
for yourself now Florence's I am three
warrior sets or is this I am brilliant
the warrior set words did I am electric
the warrior says I am often asked the
warrior to be discovery
[Music]
devil dog you're awesome thank you nice
now so wasn't extinction get my hammer
sod ladies and gentlemen
[ __ ] give it up for sure
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
just a quick question the question would
you just hear God was going on before
and what's changed for you Tony um it's
just been a lock up inside of me forever
I've had a speech impediment I've
stuttered my entire life guys 30 years
of stuttering stammering but that was
the condition that I chose I chose to
stay there I chose to identify instead
of why I was afraid of greatness I was
afraid of my life shine but no more
because today I am the boy today I am
the warrior to day life will be thanks
to day I thought in the moment every
time I knew that I would be are they
talking to councils outs of people thank
you for the pain everyone up the because
you're all here today is up to you begin
you my story
this is you me that you got me now get
you
no way
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I love to know have you
seen the video yet if not did you like
it if you've seen it already did you
like it too let me know your comments
leave it down there below I'm really
curious to find out
this is also an experimental series this
best of Toni's series on this channel so
if you wanted to continue let me know
leave it below share the video up if
this series has the impact that I'm
looking for then we'll continue not on
something else so your viewership makes
a big difference in the deciding factor
here so thank you guys again for
watching I hope you enjoyed it I believe
in you obviously need to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love please